[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ce numéro
exceptionnel
d'investigation dans quelques semaines
la nouvelle calédonie ce territoire
français du pacifique a rendez vous avec
son histoire le 4 novembre ses habitants
devront se prononcer sur le référendum
d'autodétermination c'est pour cela que
je suis ici à nouméa sur la place des
cocotiers pour commencer cette émission
je dois d'abord accomplir un chemin
continue et il me conduit sur l'île
d'ouvéa plutôt que de vous expliquer en
quoi cela consiste suivez-moi
[Musique]
et
elle est l'une des trois îles loyauté
voisine de la grande-terre ouvéa
surnommée l'île la plus proche du
paradis théâtre pourtant d'une tragédie
le 5 mai 1988 l'assaut est lancé ce jour
là pour libérer des gendarmes prise en
otage par des militants indépendantistes
le bilan est lourd 21 morts
trente ans plus tard jour pour jour
emmanuel macron seront sur place par
volonté d'apaisement le président ne
participe pas au dépôt de gerbe sur la
tombe des militants kanaks tué en 1988 a
ouvert
il est le premier président français à
se rendre sur l'île sa visite est bien
accueillie par la majorité des habitants
qui voient là un geste d'apaisement pour
d'autres la date est mal choisi s'agit
d'une provocation
c'est dans ce mémorial au sud de l'île
corps oppose les corps des 19 militants
kanaks tué au cours de l'assaut du gign
français
[Musique]
la tragédie d'ouvéa est le point
culminant d'une période de tension et de
conflit entre indépendantistes et
loyalistes partisans de la nouvelle
calédonie française au milieu des années
80 des barrages sont dressés et les
affrontements sont meurtriers des
miliciens des deux camps contrôle le
territoire la sphère de la prise
d'otages d'ouvéa voici les premières
images qui ont été tournées
[Musique]
attaque sanglante de la gendarmerie
suivie d'une prise d'otages dans un
secteur particulièrement difficile
d'accès aux salles
le paroxysme des événements est apte en
1988 un commando indépendantiste attaque
la gendarmerie d'ouvéa quatre gendarmes
sont tués et 27 autres prises en otage
nous sommes entre les deux tours de
l'élection présidentielle
françois mitterrand s'oppose alors à
jacques chirac premier ministre qui
ordonne l'assaut pour libérer les otages
retenus depuis deux semaines dans une
grotte au nord de l'île
le gign est dépêché sur place depuis
paris échec des négociations
et puis l'issue sanglante que l'on
connaît
[Musique]
une page sombre de l'histoire
calédonienne
l'émotion est encore vive pour ceux qui
l'ont vécue nous sommes retournés dans
la tribu de gossanah quelques km de la
grotte là où vit l'un des rares preneurs
d'otages rescapés de l'assaut
bonjour bonjour
merci de m'accueillir
merci à toi je fais ce geste pour te
remercie de bien vouloir m'accueillir
merci beaucoup
je voulais te remercier c'est la
première fois que que j'accomplis la
coutume et je me sens vraiment honoré de
l'accomplir avec toi parce que tu es
celui qui contribue à ce que la mémoire
des 19 soit encore aujourd'hui je suis
très émue
benoiton gopee 53 ans était à l'époque
chargé de surveiller les gendarmes dans
la grotte est également là c'est
beaucoup
merci pour le geste c'est moi je fais
partie du groupe
je
sais
on n'est pas des gens mais chauray
quand on est parti à la gendarmerie
c'est aller occuper la gendarmerie
tu étais aussi j'étais dedans gt gt
parmi les
et
c'est là que le tout a foiré
cette statue avec l âge j'avais 23 24
ces jeunes
comme les autres membres du commando
benoît bénéficié de l'amnistié générale
master d'aider ceux qui sont requis
était de voir un gros travail
le premier a su nous on est rentré dans
la grotte le premier assaut ils ont
éliminé tout le tour de
sentinelle un retour de la
pause 12-12 13 postes autour de la
grotte
fois qu'il parlait de barbares mais là
il en a vu c'est quoi c'est qui les
barbares quoi la barbarie quoi ils ont
fait leur
aujourd'hui c'est plus la colère la
tristesse que tu as dans ton coeur la
colère non
c'est je suis tranquille
là je continue à travailler à faire mon
travail j'arrête pas je reçois les
associations je reçois des élèves et ses
comptes il a témoigné de raconter ce qui
s'est passé ça veut dire on peut encore
avancer bah oui
ya toujours de l'espoir tant qu'on est
des boubaghla ya toujours de l'espoir
ce drame fait l'effet d'un électrochoc
deux mois plus tard le leader
indépendantiste jean-marie tjibaou et
son opposant loyalistes jacques lafleur
signent les accords de matignon
première étape vers la réconciliation
[Musique]
dix ans plus tard un nouveau texte est
signé l'accord de nouméa c'est le début
d'un processus d'émancipation de la
nouvelle calédonie avec à la clé un
référendum sur son indépendance
canet qui indépendante ou calédonie
française l'heure du choix pour les 270
mille habitants du territoire
près de la moitié a moins de 30 ans et
n'étaient pas nés au moment des
événements pourtant ce sont les
bulletins de vote des jeunes qui
pèseront dans l'ue en novembre prochain
[Musique]
oui
bianca 25 ans n'a pas connu cette époque
d'affrontements c'est décidé elle votera
contre l'indépendance yale a ses raisons
cette diplômée de droit prépare à
distance le concours du barreau
elle est l'une des huit élèves caledonia
bénéficier de cette préparation en
partenariat avec la sorbonne
[Musique]
je trouve que c'est vraiment une chance
en fait de pouvoir
bénéficier de la prépa de la sorbonne
qui est quand même certainement la
meilleure ou en tout cas une des
meilleures préparations et une des plus
grandes écoles de droit de france bon
voilà c'est financièrement et puis même
humainement parfois on n'a pas forcément
envie de partir tout de suite rond et
prendre du temps où financièrement on
préfère attendre ouais c'est vrai que
c'est vraiment une chance de pouvoir
faire la préparation ici être calédonien
c'est être franc c'est aussi ça va
ensemble je vois pas ça autrement et si
demain l'université en nouvelle
calédonie ou en tout cas l'enseignement
n'est plus français
va falloir tout recommencer à zéro pour
pouvoir avoir d un enseignement déjà de
qualité et puis un enseignement reconnu
à l'international des diplômes reconnus
internationalement
ça va être un petit peu compliqué à mon
avis
depuis deux ans et dans la perspective
du référendum bianca a décidé de
s'engager politiquement
elle milite au sein du rassemblement les
républicains
ce soir elle participe à une réunion de
campagne pour préparer le scrutin avec
la branche jeunesse du parti
leur objectif convaincre les jeunes
électeurs de voter non à l'indépendance
pour rappel le coeur de cible pour le
référendum semble en tout cas ce sont
des mélanésiens parce que
les indécis majoritairement
indépendantiste il beaucoup d'indécis
est le deuxième coeur de cible ce sont
les jeux parce que l'intéressé ne savent
pas envie de voter sans foot
donc nous on a vraiment du boulot sûr
sur cette deuxième catégorie on va
appeler ça comme ça
selon les projections une majorité des
néo-calédoniens seraient opposés à
l'indépendance une majorité d'autant
plus nette dans la province sud la zone
urbaine du territoire
là où vivent la plupart des participants
de la réunion
des jeunes comme nous on a toujours
connu ça ce qu'on veut ce que nous
vivons aujourd'hui on n'a pas demandé à
voter oui ou non et demain on va nous
dire battue va déplacer tu vas te
déplacer tu vas te mettre son bulletin
dans l'urne et si si oui eh ben tu aura
plus d'essence tu vas payer trois fois
plus cher tétons internet tu vas pouvoir
te faire
allez avoir des soins de santé +1
gratuite un niveau d'éducation beaucoup
plus faible et peut-être qu'un niveau de
scolarité payant et ben voilà c'est un
niveau de qualité qui va être forcément
dégradé et ça il faut en avoir
pleinement conscience il est là le
principal risque on prend le cas du
vanuatu qui est inquiets a été
indépendant on a vu ce que ça a donné
aujourd'hui il ya une vraie pauvreté et
on n'a pas du tout envie de vivre ça
aujourd'hui on a envie de continuer à
vivre dans un pays prospère avec une
santé avec une économie qui fonctionne
bien avec des gens qui arriva à comment
dire à subvenir à leurs besoins et puis
vivre ensemble c'est extrêmement
important on a un métissage qui
extraordinaire en nouvelle calédonie on
a beaucoup de choses à apprendre des
autres donc on veut continuer à vivre en
paix en sérénité dans dans la sérénité
le vanuatu l'exemple sans cesse mis en
avant par ses militants
l'ancienne colonie voisine instable
économiquement et politiquement depuis
son accession à l'indépendance
à les écouter c'est ce qui pend au nez
de la nouvelle-calédonie
107 france est vraiment à sedan un saut
dans le vide et on sait pas vraiment où
on va aller et que nous en fait partie
de cette génération qui n'a connu que la
paix puisque depuis depuis l'accord de
matignon vit en paix et que on n'a pas
envie que ça change et que on pense on
est persuadé que la france sait vraiment
ce qui nous permettra de garder ce
niveau de paix ces premiers s'imiter
entre les jeunes du rassemblement et les
100 francs si c'est ça ce qui nous unit
aussi
par tous français enfin tous français
c'est quand même ce qui unit les gens
c'est premier critère qui va venir les
gens en pensent
beaucoup d'observateurs jugent
aujourd'hui le rapport de force
favorable aux loyalistes majoritaire de
longue date aux élections locales
les accords de 1988 et 1990 ont prévu de
larges transferts de compétences
la nouvelle calédonie est aujourd'hui la
plus autonome des collectivités
françaises
elle possède son propre congrès sorte de
parlement local et son gouvernement
voici son porte parole nicolas mensdorf
il est membre de la majorité
non-indépendantiste et il défend
aujourd'hui un projet de construction
d'une centrale à gaz
l'objectif c'est toujours de vrais pour
l'intérêt général du pays donc mettre en
oeuvre cette centrale qui va bénéficier
aux calédoniens à travers
l'environnement à travers les progrès en
termes de santé trente ans après les
événements d'ouvéa et les accords de
matignon la question de l'indépendance
structure toujours la vie politique
calédonienne
et face à nicolas menchov le congrès
composé de 25 membres indépendantistes
et 29 membres non indépendantiste
des bons
bien
à tout juste 30 ans il est membre du
gouvernement en charge du budget et des
questions agricoles il a connu une
carrière éclair avant de se hisser au
sommet des institutions calédonienne
avec le parti loyaliste de centre droit
de calédonie ensemble
il fait campagne pour le non à
l'indépendance
plusieurs membres du gouvernement de
l'histoire du pays ça c'est sûr après
tant mieux on a un président de la
république qui à 39 ans on peut avoir
des membres du gouvernement de la
nouvelle-calédonie de 29 ans ava femme
objet exceptionnel
le nom qui n'ont pas ce que je souhaite
pas être jugé sur ma jeunesse il ya des
jeunes qu'on est des vieux cons il faut
être un jeune beau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
al'approche du vote le jeune élu bas la
compagne de la grande terre pour
rencontrer les habitants
et l'objectif c'est de présenter aux
gens du nord un petit peu le projet que
porte calédonie ensemble dans le cadre
du référendum d'autodétermination de la
nouvelle qu'elle ça nous ramène aussi
bien les pieds sur terre parce que les
gens de brousse sont plutôt en direct
ils nous rappellent très vite les
fondamentaux de la vie publique au parc
en soit totalement déconnecté aussi dans
nos tours d'ivoire ceci on reste au
congrès au gouvernement après on ne
ressent plus ce que veut la population
et c'est comme ça après quand commença à
perdre les pédales
il a fait son collège en brosse le lycée
à nouméa un master à strasbourg c'est en
nouvelle calédonie qu'il a décidé de
faire carrière
[Musique]
au programme ce soir une réunion
publique dans la commune rurale de
koumac
l'objectif convaincre les indécis
[Musique]
dans la salle beaucoup d'européens mais
aussi des kanaks un public qui a du mal
à se positionner à quelques semaines du
vote moi vous savez je suis né en 88
depuis que je suis née en parle de ce
référendum et de la sortie de l'accord
de nouméa et ben moi j'ai hâte qu'on en
finisse parce qu'on a des choses à faire
un bout d'un moment faudra sortir de
cette question et qu'il faudra bosser
parce qu'il faudra donner des toits nos
enfants faudra se donner à manger à nos
enfants faudra donner des emplois nos
enfants un jour faudra aussi comment
s'occupe de ça et qu'on arrête de perdre
du temps sur ces questions qui
aujourd'hui on le voit bien arrivent à
leur terme voilà
moi l'indépendance je comprends
parfaitement soudé kanak mais leur
dépendance est d'abord la colonisation m
pas l'ignorer
je suis descendante de banias où
des de l'histoire moi je comprends très
bien la démarche est telle qu'à ma tête
je
lis votre position à vous allez voter
quoi le 4 novembre en fait vous savez
pas encore
en baroeul devrait savoir je suis
européenne les venger un port
j'ai apprécié la provincialisation
j'apprécie le travail fait par les élus
ils permettent
de rester encore un peu dubitatif
aidé au transport en
france
je suis français parce qu'on est
français c'est comme ça c'est l'histoire
comme ça quand même notamment des
français
moi j'ai plein d'amis et pour autant
vous n'allez pas voter oui à la trappe
mais le grand bassin
aulas
mais gore ses réponses en temps les
prochaines fois
rendez-lui la mt sur moi vous allez voir
les pensions
l'accord scellé
cent soixante mille électeurs pourront
voter le jour du référendum le corps
électoral a été modifié pour l'occasion
est limitée aux personnes justifiant
d'un intérêt sur place et d'une certaine
ancienneté
on
n'est pas prêt
il me manque la compétence beaucoup de
choses la génération à venir où notre
génération il décidera un jour nous
rendre dépendants sexuels mais pour bien
la préparer avec toutes les personnes
qui vivent ici travaillent pour
gouvernement
[Musique]
le plus important c'est qu'au lendemain
du référendum qu'il n'y ait pas
d'affrontement entre indépendantistes et
non indépendantiste ça serait dommage de
retourner une guerre civile c'est pas
l'objectif l'objectif c'est la paix
d'autant qu'on connaît un peu le
résultat du référendum en avance parce
qu'on sait le rapport de force entre les
indépendantistes et les non
indépendantistes en nouvelle calédonie
il est favorable aux partisans du
maintien dans la france et donc l'idée
c'est qu'on lendemain du référendum
quand le oui à la france l'aura emporté
que l'on se retrouve avec les
indépendantistes main dans la main
[Musique]
on
la position loyalistes mais modérée de
nicolas metzdorf elle peut aussi
s'expliquer par ses origines
contrairement à la majorité des membres
du gouvernement local lui il a grandi en
brousse c'est la nouvelle calédonie
rural la province il est de ceux qui
sont fiers d'être attaché à la france il
est de ceux également qui sont fiers que
leur territoire soit devenu français
avant nice où l'alsace lorraine et ce
discours il l'entend depuis tout petit
sur l'exploitation agricole familiale de
ses parents à poya c'est dans le nord de
la province sud
chanté
lavrov calédonienne la beauce profonde
les parents de nicola madoff font partie
de la génération de calédoniens qui a
vécu les événements de près et qui se
sont ici chez eux
et l'un et l'autre vous êtes d'abord
caldoches calédoniens français
d'abord calédonien d'abord calédonien
français qu'elle devient français est ce
que vous avez peur du 5 novembre du
lendemain des élections ne me fait pas
peur pas du tout
de toute façon avec mon épouse nous on a
pris une décision il ya déjà de
nombreuses années on a dit nos racines
sont ici
on ne partira pas voilà ce que mon
épouse du côté de sa maman c'est une des
premières familles c'est
1843 43
ils sont là bon un peu plus vieux donc
vous voulez on va aller où on parle
beaucoup de l'identité kanak est ce qu
est ce que l'identité caldoches elle est
difficile également à définir très
difficile alors tout ça maintenant
depuis depuis ces fameux événement de
2,84 la parole s'est libérée et est donc
maintenant les gens se revendique dit
l'abbé moi mon nom mon aïeul est arrivé
ici lui faire les fers aux pieds lot il
arrivé libre c'est là et ça c'est en
train de devenir une identité mais il
faut du temps pour faire une identité
les kanaks représente près de 40% de la
population les descendants d'européens
presque trente
sept heures qui a accueilli ses ancêtres
claude considère qu'elle est aussi la
sienne même s'il reconnaît que des
kanaks long foulée avant lui
la famille mais off on a toujours vécu
avec les kanaks c'est un vieux kanak qui
s'occupait de moi ça vient quand même de
la tribu de nerfs
c'est lui qui me portait sur ses épaules
c'est lui qui m'emmenait promener c'est
lui qui m'a appris à pêcher c'est lui
qui m'a pas chasser c'est lui qui m'a un
prix
qui m'appelait un tas de choses à
grandir
moi j'étais comme ça je suivais michel
j'appelais michel boyé je suivais michel
c'était ma nounou quoi mes grands
parents devant grand père ma grand mère
avait une terre entre les tribus degois
paiement faouët et là il faisait de
l'élevage
mais il avait eu l'intelligence
dont c'était levage d'intégrer les
kanaks déchets des tribus et faisait
l'élevage ensemble c'est à dire que les
troupeaux étaient mélangés
c'était le développement commun sous
développement commun
que ce soit les calédoniens eux mêmes ou
l'état
à un moment donné ils n'ont pas pris
conscience
du fond du problème
qui était la revendication des terres
d'accord la spoliation des terres
ça existe et on peut pas dire là ya pas
eu de probation de terre c'est pas vrai
il ya eu moi je dis que le premier qui
aurait dû mettre la main dans la poche
c'est l'état
tant que fan ou ont spolié c'est d'état
et donc c'était à eux de faire le
premier pas et ne l'ont pas fait pour
montrer l'exemple pour montrer l'exemple
pour montrer l'exemple
parce que c'est vrai que certaines
tribus étaient très très à l'étroit
est ce que votre ligne politique ou même
votre engagement il est différent de
celui de nicolay si oui en quoi
l'engagement ils obligés de les
différents à mon avis que toi manche
pour quelles raisons
c'est l'époque
l'époque n'est plus la même
nicolas lui il est arrivé que les
accords de matignon
elle est née le 20 mai 88 donc quelques
jours après la tragédie de busan a
donc lui l'a vécu il a vécu toute cette
période
matignon nouméa et cetera
dans une famille où on a toujours été
engagés politiquement le combat qu'ils
mènent maintenant
auquel j'avais rend bien sûr
complètement complètement complètement
c'est un combat où on parle de partage
on est pour la france un super il reste
pour la france mais avec plus de partage
c'est à dire
essayer d'aller aux confins
aux confins de l'autonomie
mes chances d'avoir l'indépendance
[Musique]
la terre sera encore une fois au coeur
du débat dans les années à venir
nous voici dans la région de poing boot
au nord de la grande terre au lycée
agricole michel rocard
une opportunité pour un secteur que les
jeunes tendent à délaisser au profit de
la ville
il sarah et william sont étudiantes en
deuxième année de bts agricole
[Musique]
on va les laisser
les pousse
à 19 ans ces jeunes filles ont déjà
tracé leur avenir
ma famille dans l'élevage
et depuis tout petit je suis dedans ça
du coup j'aimerais continuer à augmenter
à court terme il ya les autres
là
c'est mon cal la f1 depuis petit jeu
dans sa d'en monter à cheval leur entrée
le bétail fait tout ça tu te serais pas
vu à nouméa alors pas du tout non je
suis je vis en brousse et j'aimerais
continuer à rester ici
voilà seuls deux enfants en général
c'est de l'ariège
95% des terres agricoles calédonienne
sont consacrées à l'élevage bovin un
secteur qui représente près de 900
exploitation et emploie 2500 personnes
steven blom et le directeur de
l'exploitation utilisé par le lycée ils
encadrent les élèves depuis 22 ans
l'agriculture calédonienne est en train
de de changer ces jeunes
quand une vision différente de
l'agriculture par rapport à leurs
parents donc c'est bien il faut il faut
qu'on continue à accompagner le
développement de l'agriculture
calédonienne et indépendant soupe
indépendance comment vous voyez l'avenir
de l'agriculture en cadets il faut bien
nourrir la population
donc c'est
l'agriculture sera toujours
importante en calédonie
exercice ce matin mesurer la hauteur de
l'herbe pour déterminer si les bêtes ont
des quantités suffisantes de nourriture
à les plaisirs de la hauteur de ces
trois cas le maître c'est toi qui fais
la mesure
donc là on s'est relevé
de
là on sait qu'il ya une échéance
politique en novembre vous y pensez à
l'avenir c'est danser dans vos esprits
dans vos conversations bien sûr c'est
pas pour autant qu'on va s'arrêter du et
puis je pense que dans tous les cas on
pourra s'en sortir parce qu'il ya plein
de choses à faire sur le territoire et
puis que c'est pas fini pour nous et
quand même pour développer nos futures
activités il faut quand même si posé il
faut quand même se poser un minimum de
question est de savoir comment on va
pouvoir faire ce que jusqu'à présent
c'est vrai qu'on est quand même pas mal
financée par la france donc après s'il
ya plus ça c'est comment comment ils
vont faire pour nous aider voilà si on
veut développer un projet là ça va
peut-être si on devient dépendant ça va
être difficile pour nous plus tard quoi
si on veut développer un projet monté
notre exploitation
le lycée agricole attire des jeunes de
toute la grande terre et même des îles
loyauté comme liliane originaire de
lifou
j'arrivais ici l'année dernière je
n'étais pas choquer mais ça m'a fait
vraiment un choc de voir que sur ce
petit caillou on à diverses
on a dû par une diversité de cultures
genre on peut passer de d'une culture
genre on est très belle et on arrive ici
c'est autre chose on n'a pas besoin
d'aller loin pour voir autre chose et
par soe j'avais jamais vu de caldoches
enfin de quel deuxième bloc mais n'ont
pas de bons mais
n'ont pas bien il ya des blancs à lille
frau mais cédric binauld maintenance et
des oreilles alors que ici cdc descalzos
je croise et des collants c'est ils ont
leur culture bien à elle comme nous on a
le plus dur bien à nous et apprécié
voilà on apprend à vivre avec eux et
c'est génial quoi ils nous apprennent
des choses comme le bétail mais on a pas
de bétail soit les îles et nous voilà si
c'est du partage de connaissances et
après dépôt de sous pas d'avoir un
destin commun tous ensemble on y est
déjà puis sera toujours ensemble ça
sonnera pas parce que des amis il va la
voir c'est pour la vie quoi les avis
c'est pour la vie sara lee la voilà deux
ans avec eux c'est leur honneur
enfin
des jeunes qui semble plus apaisée plus
ouvert au dialogue que leurs aînés
une génération qui se posent des
questions mika fois on l'avenir
[Musique]
au coeur des discussions sont l'avenir
justement autres secteurs le nickel fer
de lance de l'activité économique
sixième producteur mondial la grande
terre dispose d'environ 11 % des
réserves de nickel de la planète
[Musique]
à une heure au sud de nouméa dimitri
trink ngai 32 ans gère une société de
transport maritime de nickel
ra qui que ce soit regardez vous avez
des tahitiens vous avez des caldoches et
la voilà on a appris à travailler en
somme et on travaillera ensemble tout le
temps ce sont tes collègues ce sont des
sous traitants
ce sont des sous traitants déroule assez
qui achemine le minerai de la mine
il est un des rares kanak chefs
d'entreprise mais aussi l'un des leaders
de la branche jeune du fln ks le front
de libération kanak qui rassemble
aujourd'hui quatre partis
indépendantistes
ça c'est la guérite
justement avec ça quand avec le mélange
de taux de l'attaquant fait justement
les couverts les les voitures les
marmites les marmites cela trouve aussi
dans les ordinateurs
c'est incroyable
son parcours il est à contre-courant toi
tu elle choisit de devenir chef
d'entreprise pour quelle raison
je pense qu'à un moment donné moi
j'étais en échec scolaire parce que
moi j'ai jamais voulu apprendre le
français à l'école j'ai jamais voulu
être français moi l'école je vais
arrêter en au collège j'ai jamais voulu
un moment donné je me suis retrouvé à la
tribu mais après être entré dans la vie
active c'est pas comme si c'était la fin
du monde mais un moment donné il fallait
se sortir de là et il fallait s'occuper
de la jeunesse et c'est bien le premier
objectif que j'ai c'est est de leur
faire apprendre le savoir-faire que j'ai
abri et aujourd'hui on l'a on est je
suis fier de ça parce que je suis parti
de rien pour aujourd'hui pouvoir
pouvoir nourrir plus de plus de dix
familles et aujourd'hui voilà c est en
plus ces jeunes là encore forme d'autres
jeunes qui viennent derrière
transporteurs minier ouvriers
métallurgique le secteur du nickel
emploie près de 6000 personnes
pour dimitri l'indépendance ne mettrait
pas en péril sa bonne santé ici du côté
de la droite locale on est toujours en
train de faire la politique de la peur
pour dire que demain les kanaks auront
l'indépendance ils vont tous nous virer
tous non c'est pas vrai ici à toujours
de la place pour celui qui veut
travailler ça veut dire que ces
personnes si jamais la nouvelle
calédonie voté son indépendance elle
deviendrait quoi
elle deviendrait citoyens quand même
bien décidés reconnaît qu'ils auront
toujours leur place dakar demain quand
tu auras l'indépendance le mot kanak
c'est
cela sa signification c'est une société
multiculturelle multiethnique et sortir
de la france ça voudrait dire mettre fin
à toute relation avec la france je vais
pas vous répondre ça comme ça après
aujourd'hui on ira au 4 novembre on
sortira du 4 novembre a pas on verra si
demain on coupe les ponts avec la france
ou peut-être les pays de la mélanésie
aussi on en parle beaucoup déjà de fin
de partenariat et aussi avec
l'australie la nouvelle-zélande et haïti
tout ça merci beaucoup démontrer
[Musique]
dimitri est originaire de saint-louis
seule tribu kanake de nouméa
théâtre répétés de violence notamment en
2016 ou les jeunes et les forces de
l'ordre s'étaient affrontés pendant
plusieurs semaines
ils oeuvrent pour donner un autre visage
de sa tribu
cette structure a été construite de
toutes pièces par des jeunes de la
communauté ça c'est notre maison commune
et on se sert des deux mariages ou côté
des hommes une coutumière côtière des
repas sinon il ya aussi les études
surveillées pour les enfants qui sortent
de l'école le sort
[Musique]
du soutien scolaire assuré par des
jeunes bachelières elle même originaire
de saint louis
[Musique]
on essaye de leur apprendre vivants sont
de façon que ce soit des jeunes qu'on ne
retrouvera pas sur le bord de la route
dans 5 ou 10 ans en veut qu'ils fassent
des grands études en métropole ou dans
les pays du pacifique
voilà on les poussera jusqu'à que demain
ils croient qu'ils vont former leurs
foyers laurent nous aurons un métier
justement pour subvenir à leurs besoins
là pour vous
l'enjeu est de taille surtout si l'on se
penche sur les statistiques les
inégalités sont criantes
seulement 3% des kanak sont diplômés de
l'enseignement supérieur
huit fois moins que les noms kanak
depuis les années 80
des politiques publiques de
rééquilibrage ont été mises en place des
bourses ont également été proposées aux
jeunes kanaks souhaitant étudier en
métropole
malgré tout les chiffres de la
délinquance augmente et plus d'un tiers
d'entre eux sont au chômage
loin du quotidien de ce louis les
quartiers huppés du sud de nouméa ici
vivent principalement des calédoniens
d'origine européenne vietnamiens ou des
métropolitains c'est là que nous
retrouvons bien car j'ai souhaité
rencontrer bianca dans un cadre plus
convivial avec ses amis ce sont des
jeunes comme elle et ils vont nous
expliquer ce que représente pour eux
l'identité calédoniennes
bon jeu car bonjour vous êtes avec vos
amis dont oui bonjour là bonjour
enchanté
elle est sympa votre quand il
ya pierre ya pire comme vue
vous par exemple vous êtes dans un
courant qui appartient aux républicains
alors comment vous faites pour justement
composer avec toutes les populations de
nouvelle calédonie nous un baron par
rapport aux indépendantistes même si
nous on veut rester français
c'est ensemble c'est à dire qu'on veut
vivre ensemble de toute façon c'est le
but c'est le destin commun c'est la
nouvelle calédonie on vit tous ensemble
on vit ensemble on vit les uns à côté
des autres alors ça dépend ça dépend on
est très mélangées quand même c'est vrai
qu'après il peut y avoir il peut y avoir
peut-être ce clivage mais nous en tout
cas nous on se mélange il n'y a pas de
la fin nous on ne fait pas la différence
quoi mais il peut y avoir un certain
clivage quand même en même temps quand
on regarde le taux de chômage chez les
jeunes notamment chez les jeunes
d'origine kanak où il atteint 33% on a
le sentiment quand même que c'est plus
facile pour certains que pour d'autres
après il ya forcément les origines qui
joue on n'est pas tous égaux dans les
faits on est tous égaux en droit mais
mais c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que le
droit est là pour venir équilibrer les
choses donc oui forcément on est tous
avec des dés des origines différentes et
et des milieux sociaux différents mais
par exemple moi dans mes études j'ai été
enfin même à l'université c'est très
représentatif
il ya une majorité de kanaks c'est une
majorité kanak mais d'ailleurs c'est
parce que c'est le début c'est le début
et c'est bien après faut pas oublier
qu'en vrai cadeau nous on à l'emploi
local et donc donc peut-être que oui il
c'est une réalité les chiffres vous avez
donné par rapport au chômage pour les
kanak mais l'emploi local c'est pour les
kanaks pour les calédoniens et donc
forcément si on a un métropolitain qui
vient en nouvelle calédonie à profit
illégal on va prendre un local une
personne d'ici donc après s'il ya du
chômage peut être que c'est qui qui en a
qui ont pas forcément envie de redoubler
d'efforts pour pour travailler pour
trouver du travail et aussi et je pense
que ça sépare souvent le monde manque
dans ce cas là je pense parce qu on a
quand même énormément davantage en
nouvelle calédonie l'emploi local il est
au coeur d'un secteur porteur d'avenir
le secteur touristique
avec ses plages paradisiaques son lagon
classé au patrimoine de l'unesco le
marché concentrent des perspectives de
développement très prometteuse le
dernier établissement de luxe à avoir vu
le jour il ya deux ans et cet hôtel 5
étoiles rencontre avec le directeur
dominique michaud aujourd'hui on a
encore 60% qu'intel calédonienne et 40 %
de clientèle
australienne néo-zélandaise un petit peu
de japonais en espérant monter voilà on
veut inverser ses filles vers ces
chiffres et faire en sorte qu'ils aient
plus de deux touristes on va dire
internationaux que de touristes locaux
n'ont pas qu'on va baisser de nos
moteurs ce local millions va augmenter
l'occupation de l'hôtel
le prix des billets d'avion la
concurrence des pays voisins ont
longtemps été des entraves au
développement du secteur pourtant alors
que l'archipel plafonné avec cent mille
touristes par an en moyenne il a
enregistré un record + 20 mille
visiteurs en 2017 et des recettes
estimées à plus de 200 millions d'euros
vous pensez réellement que le tourisme
pourrait être un levier de développement
économique pour la nouvelle calédonie
alors il est heureusement qu'on y croie
que j'y croirai comme d'autres
grosse concurrence quand on regarde la
part des voisines les fidji qui sont
requis ce pas si loin que ça c'est
comment vous allez faire pour vous
démarquer rester compétitif le tourisme
mondial à des prévisions de croissance
qui sont de l'ordre
de 3 4% par an au cours des 10 15
prochaines années c'est un des rares
secteurs normand qui a des tales de
courbe de croissance visible fans dont
canon scié vous le voyez dans le secteur
de l'aérien qui va doubler aujourd'hui
on recherche des commandants de bord on
cherche un nouveau desautels dans
beaucoup d'endroits moment donc le
tourisme à une visibilité économique
très importante au cours des prochaines
années
l'hôtel mais également toutes les
activités touristiques aux alentours
sont une source d'emplois est un moteur
économique pour la commune de bourail ce
golf est sorti de terre il est
aujourd'hui le plus grand de tous le
pacifique 18 route bordée par les plages
de sable blanc
christophe et florence un couple de
nouméa sont là pour le week-end pour
s'évader de la ville
leur professeur tony champion de france
et d'europe
[Musique]
sur les épaules on prend sa position et
ont fait quelques rotations du haut du
corps pour réchauffer
ont bien c'est régulièrement on essaie
de le faire au moins trois 3 4 fois dans
l'année faut faire venir le touriste
aujourd'hui on n'a pas assez de touriste
contrairement à fidji ou tight ivre la
calédonie est un pays magnifique on
mérite autant d'avoir de tous et ce que
que d'autres élus a projeté un petit peu
de la balle
je suis originaire de nouvelle-calédonie
donc je suis parti à l'âge de 15 ans
pour jouer sur le circuit professionnel
et puis quand je suis rentré ici il se
trouve qu'à un golf a poussé à bourail
du coup c'est ce qui nous manquait je
crois quand c'est un peu toujours
contenté du nickel la joie des clous de
tourisme est en pleine explosion
et du coup on a tout à apprendre nous
les calédoniens
l'apprentissage
du tourisme l'accueil du tourisme
la perspective d'ouverture de vols
commerciaux réguliers avec la chine a de
quoi donner encore plus d'espoir aux
professionnels du tourisme
toutes les îles de l'archipel sont
aujourd'hui en train de devenir de
nouvelles destinations même les plus
sauvages comme celle-ci lifou
les premiers éco lodge ont vu le jour
sur ces teams de 9000 habitants presque
tous des kanaks
georges tient l'une des plus ancienne
auberge créé avec sa femme il ya 30 ans
[Applaudissements]
est aux tables puisque bon comme vous
voyez c'est l'entrée
c'est l'entrée du gîte alors je voudrais
embellir l'entrée et comme chaque entrée
bien il faut toujours des petits totem
devant
[Applaudissements]
là vous avez vu que c'est le poisson
dawa qui est ici et alors ici ce sera
d'avoir l'autre bungalows il y aura son
nom qui s'appellera picot ben justement
il est là il a seulement qui est là-bas
et l'autre qui va être là bas il
s'appellera le perroquet c'est les notes
des trois portions retrouvera souvent
quand on voit plus et son défi mettre en
avant l'authenticité de la culture kanak
en s'adaptant aux tendeurs du tourisme
occidental bonjour madame
qu'on va savoir ça va bien et vous êtes
bien
c'est super puis le petit savoie tu vois
on est arrivé ici hier soir pour voir un
petit peu le nord de lire les
magnifiques falaises et puissent se
promener autour des grottes des belles
plages et alors
je crois que ça parle de tout ça c'est
juste ce plan est un petit havre de paix
qu'on a fait c'est surtout allait à la
rencontre des locaux en fait parce que
ce qui nous intéresse en voyage c'est
vraiment ça
rares sont les pays où c'est aussi
simple très franchement
quand vous passez les gens vous disent
systématiquement bonjour quand vous
marchez les gens vous font
systématiquement un signe de la main
même s'ils sont en voiture les gens
n'hésitent pas s'arrêter si l'on a
l'impression que vous cherchez la
moindre information y'a rien de plus
simple
vous auriez pas peur en étant
indépendant de perge les touristes
mais je pense pas on ne pense pas mal il
ya des pays à des boîtes avant le
vanuatu et puis les élevages et tout ça
qui ont triplé au niveau de nombre de
touristes s'est passé parce que non sauf
le département puis sera pas que les
touristes viennent ici dans leur
contraire le rôle pays
beaucoup plus dansant dans son milieu
authentique
avec sa femme georges accueille des
visiteurs qu'elle est dognin et
étrangers c'est dimanche et dimanches
travaillés d'image
grâce notamment aux bateaux de croisière
en provenance de l'australie
la marche s'est baladé sa nouveauté
de la mer le coucher du soleil
les baleines la saison des baleines qui
vont arriver là voilà c'est à dire c'est
le paradis
les paradis n'est pas là c'est ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lille qui a gardé son authenticité
commence à voir revenir ses jeunes de la
grande terre pour s'y établir
traditionnellement ils partaient pour
faire leurs études faute de lycées ou
pour chercher du travail
aujourd'hui le mouvement s'inverse
[Musique]
rémy lui aussi avec une dizaine d'années
à nouméa mais il ya quatre ans il a
décidé de revenir chez lui dans la tribu
de silwan
[Musique]
c'est un mandarinier
essayer de mandarine et
tout le monde a ri il ya deux ans il
donne bien
des gens il donnera bien
il ya des avocats il ya des letchis à
des citrons il ya des caramboles il ya
des coeurs de boeuf il ya les pros
militaire à son impôt paradis si je sais
pas mais voilà il ya les tomates cerise
après partout
un véritable jardin d'éden que ce jeune
musicien et slameur a retrouvé après des
années sur la grande terre de
l'agriculture sur les îles loyauté
d'abord vivrières elle est utilisée pour
les dons et les échanges on n'est pas
contre la modernité on n'est pas figé
non plus on avance avec le temps et du
coup là on est avec l'évolution en
équilibre en avant en natation avec des
cordages maintenant il ya des clous et
puis des marteaux puis là le beatle qui
maintenant utilisent tout ça pour
pouvoir essayer d'équilibrer tout ce qui
est nature et
modernité moderne dont les beaucoup un
peuple qui s'entraînent du peuple
communautaire est très uni aurait dit
pas par là par notre culture par la
coutume par notre façon de faire est pas
encore tous à nouveau c'est un point
important pour nous est primordial de la
préserver de la conserver
[Musique]
et ça c'est une autre
4 additionnel c'est le world or c'est
tout la tribu qui construit et l'autre
qui marque un peu amer
rémy a connu le mode de vie occidental à
nouméa pour ses études mais à 33 ans il
a fait le choix de renouer avec ses
racines aujourd'hui continue à voyager
pour son armée il vit le quotidien de sa
tribu car at il ou elle a aisni a tourné
la roumanie et la
cantine
ni en tout ni la calomnie
et la queen ému d un manque d coûte
maintenant où notre culture ses cultures
de parole c'est on parle et puis après
il faut écouter comparé ces notes et
maintenant tout le monde s'écoute plus
en plus tu as internet et puis voilà
c'est plus sur les réseaux sociaux et la
culture se perd maintenant ils vont plus
au chant il faut plus aller chercher à
manger ils vont magasin
devient raciste et du coup mon travail
c'est de leur donner des outils pour
qu'ils ont confiance en nous et essayer
de construire un pays on semblait savoir
équilibrer tous et des choses pas c'est
ma vision
trouver sa place entre tradition et
modernité c'est le message que rémy veut
faire passer aux jeunes de sa tribu
aujourd'hui c'est jour de mariage et de
fête ainsi l'om tout le monde met la
main à la pâte
[Musique]
ils sont en train de préparer
chacun allait moment ils font tout ce
qui est entré ce qui est plat principal
comme vous voyez
la société kanak est structurée autour
d'une organisation coutumière très
hiérarchisé
de la presse si on est ému à d'émotion
et chacun sait quels chacun vient pour
se justifier au niveau de la relation de
sang les familles ap les clans se
regroupent en tribune il en existe près
de 350 en nouvelle calédonie certaines
existait avant la colonisation et la
plupart se sont formés au début du xxème
siècle dans les tribus le vote est
traditionnellement indépendantiste
je veux savoir en fait ce que vous
comptez voté le 4 novembre
et une idée oui
comment garder pour moi d'accord c'est
bizarre a que dans les familles
buisson
mais tous notre indépendance c'est sûr
et après voilà chacun comment ils
s'expriment moi personnellement je me
suis dit je vais pour l'indépendance
bâclée par rapport à toutes les familles
qui sont là partout les frères ce qui
est de la libye via d'autres qui va le
dire bravo bâle ville moi j'ai voté pour
un maquillage
à oui je suis fier de thénac serait pas
venir voter la france oui j'ai bien
dit ce soit niveau m nom qui va gagner
mais après voilà moi je reste ici
après voilà ça n'empêche pas de partager
ça va être génial avec toutes les
communautés
[Musique]
la famille du marié arrive
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans la culture kanak l'oncle maternel
occupe une place centrale c'est lui
symboliquement qui transmet le sang est
la vie à l'enfant il devra veiller sur
lui de sa naissance jusqu'à sa mort à
naître quasi sacré plus attendu encore
que les époux
[Musique]
c'est la crise et les jeunes de la tribu
bien qu avec le temps par la troupe de
danse de la tribu sahara pour appeler
quand les jaunes d'oeufs
j'aime des îles lampard à la capitale
mais on sait qu'on doit retourner dans
nos tribus tôt ou tard et pour moi c'est
très important de retourner parce que je
viens de comprendre qui en fait il nous
avait envoyé à l'extérieur de la tribu
pourra préparer de cet équilibre entre
tradition et modernité
je suis fier de dire à tout le monde là
pour leur dire que voilà c'est toujours
dans le petit bout de la kanaky le bayer
petit peuple les cadenas qu'ils existent
déjà ils sont tout simplement un minimum
que je sais trés une perte et pour moi
c'est pour ça je pourrais ce prix que
l'autre parce que j'ai confiance en moi
je suis fier tels que je suis devant de
ma culture et puis trompait
[Musique]
a nouméa et ses alentours où vivent 40
mille kanak il est plus difficile de
savoir d'où l'on vient de vivre sa
culture
comme posé sur la mer le centre culturel
tjibaou en hommage au leader
indépendantiste un haut lieu de la
culture kanak
c'est ici que travail odt 37 ans après
des études de sciences politiques en
métropole puis à l'université de nouméa
cette jeune femme originaire de lifou
travaille aujourd'hui pour cet
établissement qui a vu le jour avec les
accords de matignon
bonjour merci de nous recevoir dans ce
lieu emblématique du centre jean marie
tjibaou bonjour on vient de découvrir le
cas de rémy qui a fait le choix après
des années de vie ici en grande terre de
repartir à lifou est ce que cette
décision et veille quelque chose en vous
est ce que par hasard vous vous verriez
vous optez pour le même genre de
décision
c'est vraiment une démarche mais qui
m'interpelle et qui m'inspirent
mais peut-être pas pour les mêmes
raisons crémiers parce qu'on n'a pas
forcément le même parcours
j'ai jamais grandi à lifou par exemple
je ne parle pas du tout l'y faut je le
comprends un peu ça crée forcément mois
d'écart enceinte quelque chose qui
m'embrouille autres à sion une vraie
frustration en effet parce que
aujourd'hui je suis maman donc aussi
pour mes enfants et parce que dans le
ressenti
et ben c'est comme si je n'étais pas
forcément une vraie fille de lifou une
vrai qu'un acte commençait une vraie
fille il faut
bas où je pense aux yeux de mes
congénères parce que c'est vrai que la
langue c'est un élément fondateur pour
une personne parler sa langue maternelle
je ne parlons pas moi mais ma langue
maternelle je comprends que ce soit une
fierté mais du coup sacré pour moi
n'étant pas locutrice une vraie
frustration il ya une mise à distance
parce que je ne parle qu'en france est
quasiment tous les habitants de nouvelle
calédonie toutes communautés confondues
parle français mais environ 15000
personnes parlent aussi jeou la langue
vernaculaire la plus répandue sur tout
le territoire
[Musique]
comme de plus en plus de jeunes kanaks
ses élèves de seconde du lycée lapérouse
à nouméa ont choisi d'apprendre la
langue de leurs parents pour garder et
entretenir leur identité
ça
2 3
mai à nagoya quoi
les
bnl
depuis 1992 quatre des 28 langues
vernaculaires sont proposés en option au
bac à la place de l'espagnol ou
l'allemand
ok
et beaucoup c'est un peu vrai
mais si vous lâchez soit bauzou c'est un
public féminin fans il faut pas leur
honneur et je suis justement oparo à la
maison
parlez à vos enfants la langue que vous
maîtrisez justement c'est pour intégrer
le groupe il prononça fait des mois j'ai
vu tout de suite et à tous les acteurs
et où il s'en étonner et puis voilà c
est le lien qui se crée tout de suite à
wii avait parié vous après tu fais
partie de dailymotion
et ma première leçon on avait vu ce que
c'était pas la première maison
non mais le titre du dialogue
arrivé à ouallam ok maintenant nez mais
la mana reconnaît oui oui le cognac
louis c'est la langue française
[Musique]
les médecins croyaient oui
moi je suis encore toute la base la
petite base encore je ne parle pas le
veut pouvoir pouvoir parler avec mes
tantes in tout ça je fais mes grand bien
c'est comme ça que ce sera plus facile
pour ma grand mère comme elle parle pas
le litre le français pardon du coup
c'est simple facile de parler avec elle
et
avec
mes parents ils parlent de le dire ou
chez moi je comprends mais voilà je suis
là pour apprendre à parler
lui originaire du
coup ça va m'aider à parler avec les
parents les grands-parents
les langues kanak longtemps interdite
sont reconnus comme langue
d'enseignement et de culture depuis
l'accord de nouméa et depuis deux ans
des cours obligatoires de culture kanak
sont dispensés à tous les lycéens 30
minutes par semaine
l'objectif favoriser le destin commun
expression inscrite dans le préambule de
l'accord de nouméa
lorraine cassagne oeuvre elle aussi pour
le destin commun
cet ancien enseignant et médiatrice
pénale a créé un dispositif de lutte
contre les violences à l'école qui
peuvent facilement prendre un caractère
ethnique en nouvelle calédonie
la question est d'autant plus sensible
que la date du référendum approche
ce collège en périphérie de nouméa est
l'un des établissements scolaires dans
lesquels elle organise depuis quinze ans
des formations à la médiation des
conflits
du collège
nation
courroye
alors
non
cette classe de 5e va apprendre comment
désamorcer une situation de conflit
revoir les différentes étapes par
lesquelles ils vont traiter le conflit
et par lesquels ils vont offrir aux
protagonistes ma de quoi grandir grâce à
ce processus plutôt que d'en sortir
détruits voilà c'est ça l'intérêt
une heure par semaine pendant une année
c'est la durée de la formation proposée
par lauren castagne aux enseignants qui
à leur tour former leurs élèves
nous expliquer
chaque établissement qui participent au
programme forme en moyenne une quinzaine
d'élèves
avec une meilleure amie en fait et je
trouve ça vraiment bas
pas très long il sa part en fait je
m'attendais pas à
l'objectif que les jeunes médiateur
puisse résoudre les conflits sans
l'intervention des adultes si nous on
est des élèves comme vous on va à nice
look aimait rigoler tout ce que vous
allez dire ça va rester dans cette salle
et ça sortira pas en dehors donc nous on
est neutres il ya des gens qui me
disaient que l la suite hébergée et
gérée fait sa fête alors là vous connais
de plus parce que ça ne sert à rien de
faire une médiation qui ne conçoivent
pas aux insultes et on a fait une
médiation c'est pour régler votre
problème et non pas pour les embrouiller
quoi
au total lorraine cassagne intervient
dans quinze collèges et lycées
l'initiative a été étendue aux écoles
primaires cinq établissements pilotes
font le test cette année comme ici à
saint quentin quartiers sensibles de
nouméa
le plus gros profit que je sais quand tu
es josé jamal est alors et 666 sens bien
sultan plus d'insulter leur pain
ben j'aurais contre les gens dit la
vérité on est quand même dans une école
les cultures sont très luxe et des
enfants issus de pas mal de détenir mais
la médiation à ça qu'elle apporte cette
compréhension de l'autre de se dire tu
es comme moi on est tous pareils on est
tous issus des mêmes milieux même s'il
ya quelques petites différences même si
chez toi c'est pas pareil même si tes
parents sont un petit peu plus riches
soit un petit peu moins bien logés
pourquoi pas mais on est tous dans
l'acceptation de l'autre de mieux en
mieux et pour l'avenir du pays
la graine aller planter ya plus tard on
faisait du bien de moi j'aimerais finir
de vous à moi je suis trop fier de moi
la médiation
[Applaudissements]
le dialogue la base éducative de la paix
sociale une des clés pour construire ce
fameux destin commun
d'autres ont décidé de miser sur la
musique pour établir une passerelle
entre les communautés des communautés
qui se mélangent encore trop peu
voici hugo et john deux calédoniens qui
se sont lancés dans un projet inédit
mixez musiques électroniques et musiques
traditionnelles kanak
[Musique]
ok
wada c'est le nom de leur groupe
cohésion celui de leur premier album
lundi j'ai l'autre ingénieur du son
ensemble ils sillonnent la nouvelle
calédonie de tribu en tribu avec leur
studio d'enregistrement mobile
leur musique est un mélange détonnant d'
instruments ancestraux de chant kanak et
de rythme électro
cap au nord ce matin ils se rendent dans
la tribu de l'année où tu as et la
troisième résidence musicale qu'ils
organisent là bas
dans cette région traditionnellement
indépendantiste mais où les deux jeunes
loyalistes ont tissé des liens grâce à
la musique j'en voulais vous remercier
nos à claire et voilà nous avec john on
est encore venu ici pour attraper de la
musique la traditionnelle qu'on est venu
pour aller chercher les instruments fort
elle est fabriquée pour bien faire du
son et
voilà on est touché encore d'être là
avec vous en espérant que ça puisse
montrer qu'on peut travailler ensemble
et qu'on peut faire des belles choses
ensemble
donc voila merci beaucoup
merci bien guy geste comme
on retourne à bouffer petit gestion et
les six grandes eaux satisfaire votre
besoin merci beaucoup
[Musique]
le groupe prend la direction de la forêt
pour trouver de quoi fabriquer les
instruments traditionnels
les instruments kanak sont utilisés
depuis des siècles dans les grandes
occasions les rituels les cérémonies
coutumières les fêtes
des écorces de figues et pour les
percussions du bonbon sont les flûtes
ça va être
fait le départ là bas
ce
parti
toutes ces connaissances au niveau
sonore que nos ancêtres nous ont légué
et maintenant le partage arrive je
promets c'est une transmission chances
d'une transmission de ce savoir la
nuance est quand même ces fonds ne sait
ni quand c'est allez allez allez voir
d'autres horizons aller voir d'autres
horizons
ils veulent et c'est surtout chez nous
de cannes accueillera le voit sauter par
dessus les barrières aller voir pierre
l'autre côté
go go go
si les conflits ethniques remontent aux
années 80 ils ont laissé des traces des
barrières tacite entre les communautés
cette rencontre est suffisamment rare
encore aujourd'hui pour comprendre
l'importance d'une volonté de construire
un avenir commun
[Musique]
à plusieurs façons d'excuser les bambous
s class est resté je partage ça se joue
à plusieurs quoi ça ne te réponds
[Musique]
fait
partager
ma culture avec
c'est une première pour moi ces pays lui
aussi de ses premières pour ces partages
symboliquement ce soit d'autre au fond
ça veut dire qu'il comprend
il comprend le peuple quand même
[Musique]
c'est un studio à ciel ouvert qu hugo et
john ont installé cette musique c'est
son cas n'a qu ils vont les faire
découvrir un tout autre public à nous et
à charles quint je rêve
tous les habitants viennent
d'enregistrer un rythme un champ un
accord
de jours de travail et un nouveau
morceau à la clé un de plus pour le
deuxième album qu'il prépare
[Musique]
deby
c'est la richesse justement n'est-ce pas
ça nous permet de pouvoir
partager toutes ses cultures ses
collègues qui connaît sa soute hume pour
levis déjà énergie ça il ya plein de
gens qu'ils vivent à ce destin commun
qu'on ne monte pas c'est de la folie
on est en plein dedans
[Musique]
m
aïe
[Musique]
samedi
une chanson pour peut-être suivre le
même chemin une chanson en tout cas pour
terminer ce documentaire réalisé en
immersion la nouvelle calédonie a
désormais son destin entre les mains
ap
[Musique]
ça lance je sais
les moulins